[Applause]
well we're in the center of Hesson City
we're actually in a a particularly
residential area the prosecutor's office
is just to my left you can see the
Rescue Services are trying to go bit by
bit down areas that once were covered
roads in the center of the city to try
and find out if there are any stragglers
there are already hundreds
maybe thousands of people who have
already been evacuated to Odessa and
mikalaya
there are Red Cross Vans as you can see
and a lot of other volunteers circling
the flooded areas we are talking as you
said about
18 Cubit kilometers of water which has
been Unleashed and the flood waters have
been washing down uh slowly but surely
swallowing up about a hundred villages
and towns including hairson City the
capital of Quezon region which is on the
Ukrainian controlled side of the
territory the donipro River cuts through
and over which the dam traverses is cut
in two with the ukrainians on the the
south west bank and the Russians have
occupied the south east bank now we
understand
there has been a torrent of comments on
social media and
um Twitter and any other post that you
can imagine including Ukrainian in fact
even as we're standing here the waters
are rising and getting deeper
blaming Russia to this calling it active
the most the strongest and the biggest
environmental disaster in Europe for
decades
um president zielinski has been not only
very active on his own Twitter handle
but also addressing the Bucharest nine
his East European Partners calling on
them once again and calling on the World
to back Ukraine to back their entry to
join NATO and very firmly saying that
Russia is responsible for this calling
it a terrorist act saying it's
equivalent to deploying a weapon of mass
destruction and saying quite
categorically that there is no doubt in
his mind and in the the minds of the
ukrainians that the Russians were
responsible for laying mines and the
explosion went off inside the dam
structure and of course that contravenes
uh key articles of the Geneva Convention
and International law and would
constitute a war crime bombing or
exploding destroying a structure which
supplies water to millions of people
drinking water as they say on both sides
of Ukraine control territory and
russian-controlled territory but also it
was identified very early on by
president zelenski that the dam was
seized by Russia right at the start of
of the war in February and they have
maintained possession of it up until now
president zielinski warned in October
and urged the West to take action to try
and protect the dam because he warned
then that he feared it would be used to
as a weapon against civilians and
certainly the the there is a lot of a
argument with the Russians denying that
they've done this saying that um their
various officials claiming that Ukraine
did this this explosion that Ukraine is
using it because they're failing in
their much vaunted and much trailed
counter-offensive yesterday if you
remember the Russians went all out with
their social media propaganda and news
reports claiming that they had
attacked and destroyed a number of
Ukrainian tanks and killed several
hundred Ukrainian soldiers in a a failed
attempt to to try and push into the
Danette region one of the occupied
territories that Russia has claimed as
its own but I think to answer that
question who is responsible clearly uh
the the the ukrainians have most to lose
by this it is it is going to hamper any
possible counter offensive because it's
tying up a huge amount of resources
including Emergency Services it's
flooding a huge area of Southern Ukraine
much of which is dependent on
agricultural X support drinking water
supply of energy the destruction of the
novakovska hydroelectric plants supplies
energy to millions of people in South
Ukraine but also on the other side from
the Russian point of view it their
cities and their Villages under the
russian-controlled area are also
affected we've seen pictures coming out
of novoca itself showing the the main
area the main Square flooded as well and
of course this this water the water from
this Dam the water from the reservoir
not only is used to for the cooling
towers in the zaparisha nuclear power
plant which is to the north also under
Russian control but also supplies water
drinking water to those in
russian-occupied Crimea in in the South
and that will obviously have a big
impact on those residents there and
indeed on hundreds of thousands of
civilians